good evening my name is Walker Molly I
am a junior economics major from Pine
Grove Mills Pennsylvania I'd like to
welcome dr. John marini John marini is a
professor of political science at the
University of Nevada Reno a former
visiting distinguished fellow at
hillsdale's Allen p Kirby jr. Center for
Constitutional studies and citizenship
in Washington DC dr. marini earned his
BA at San Jose State University and his
PhD in government at the claremont
graduate school he serves on the board
of directors of the claremont institute
which awarded him the henry salvatori
prize in the american founding in 2011
dr. marini served in the Reagan
administration as a special assistant to
Justice Clarence Thomas who was then
chairman of the Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission he is the author
of numerous popular and scholarly
articles on politics political theory
and film especially the films of John
Ford and the author or editor of several
books including the Imperial Congress
crisis in the separation of powers and
the politics of budget control Congress
the presidency and the growth of the
administrative state please join me in
welcoming John marini
well thank you can you hear me
everything is it's all right I just
seems like some of my classes everyone's
in the back way up here I was asked to
speak on Frank Capra and America as many
of you know capper was not born in
America so he was not an American by
birth or blood consequently he did not
understand America in terms of any
personal category of identity such as
race ethnicity gender or sexuality those
categories that determine the good only
with reference to one's own like Abraham
Lincoln he understood America in terms
of its public or political principles
those principles that establish the
ground of a common good for Capra it was
the moral principles of America that
could be shared by those who could
understand them and those willing to
live up to them the problem of the
meaning of American citizenship is not a
new one as Abraham Lincoln noted in
Chicago in 1858 after the American
founders many of the new citizens did
not share the blood of the founding
fathers but Lincoln said with the
establishment of the principle of the
Declaration of Independence and I'm
quoting Lincoln now in the Declaration
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal then they
feel that moral sentiment taught in that
day evidences their relation to those
men that it is the father of our moral
principle in there and that they have a
right to claim it as though it were
blood of the blood in flesh of the flesh
of the men who wrote that declaration
and so they are that is the electric
cord in that declaration that links the
hearts of
patriotic and liberty-loving men
together that will link those patriotic
hearts as long as the love of freedom
exists in the minds of men throughout
the world that's the end of Lincoln's
quote it was the electric cord that
bound Frank Capra to America for Capra
America was not merely a country blessed
with natural resources and beauty but it
was a the embodiment of those principles
of equality and liberty his whole life
professional and personal was animated
by those ideas Frank capper was born in
Sicily in 1897 and came to America 1903
when he was 6 years old yet by the 1930s
and 40s Frank Capra's movies were said
to embody the best in America the film's
Frank Capra made for Columbia during the
1930s were hailed by critics and the
American public alike his films received
35 academy award nominations they won
eight academy awards including two for
Best Picture and three for Best Director
only two other men have ever won that
many Best directing Oscars William Wyler
13 is same as Capra and John Ford 14 but
Capra's star faded after the Second
World War by the end of the
revolutionary decade of the 1960's the
actor and director John Cassavetes could
say maybe there was never in America in
the 1930s maybe it was all Frank Capra
end quote by that time Capra's films
were filled were viewed as feel good
fantasies about a country that never was
the criticism of Capra had only revealed
a growing crisis in the understanding of
the meaning of America the artists and
in election perhaps some of the people
cells no longer understood American the
way the same way as the pre-war
generation had did the earlier
generation of Americans understand the
real America or was that America merely
a storybook Tim made up by Frank cap and
where the Americans who were moved by
his art merely naive yet America become
real only after the 1960s in order to
answer that question we must ask what
was Capra's view of America was it the
way in which the Americans had
understood themselves how should America
understand itself that is the question
is it in the terms of its founding
principles made intelligible with
reference to the eternal laws of nature
and reason or must America be understood
in terms of a process established by the
contending economic and social forces of
history in which success itself
determines the proper outcome or as
Lincoln posed the question the
alternatives can they only be understood
in terms of might or right when Lincoln
was confronted with this dilemma he
turned to a defense of the founders not
because it was his own merely but
because it was right or good in the
Lyceum address he said and I quote from
Lincoln again we found our we find
ourselves under the government of a
system of political institutions
conducing more essentially to the ends
of civil and religious liberty than any
of which the history of former times
tells us we when mounting the stage of
existence found ourselves the legal
inheritors of these fundamental
blessings we toiled not in the
acquirement or establishment of them
they are laid legacy bequeathed to us by
a once hearty brave and patriotic but
now lamented and departed race of
ancestors theirs was the
task and nobly they performed it to
possess themselves and threw themselves
us of this godly layer goodly land and
to up rear upon its hills and valleys a
political edifice of liberty and equal
rights tis ours only to transmit these
the former unpro feigned by the foot of
an invader the latter undecayed by the
lapse of time and untoward by usurpation
to the latest generation that fate shall
permit the world to know this task of
gratitude to our fathers justice to
ourselves duty to posterity and love for
our species in general all imperative ly
require us faithfully to perform how
shall how then shall we perform it
that's all link that was his question
how then shall we perform it Capra like
Lincoln assumed the political edifice of
Liberty and equal rights is a
fundamental good the problem for Capra
therefore was the same as Lincoln's how
shall we perform our duty to our fathers
for our good is in our inheritance our
treasure is in the ideas of the founders
it is the duty of each generation to
make those ideas live through the proper
kind of education which keeps them alive
and it is important to celebrate the
deeds of those ordinary individuals who
continue to exercise the virtues
necessary to maintain those ideas
because he thought that the best of our
fathers is greater than we are kapor
rejected every social or economic theory
that rested upon the idea of progress or
a philosophy of history yet it was such
a view based on the supposed rationality
of the historical process itself that
established the dominant ideologies of
the 20th cent of twentieth century
thought it was assumed that those
historical categories understood in
terms of society and economic
reduce morality to mass movements
mobilized by will to power made
legitimate through economic and social
struggle made moral in the categories of
class and race as hannah arendt he was
German theorists observed right in the
middle of the Second World War she said
among ideologies few have won enough
prominence to survive the hard
competitive struggle of persuasion and
only to have come out on top essentially
defeated all others the ideology which
interprets history is an economic
struggle of classes and the other that
interprets history is a natural fight of
races the appeal of both to large masses
was so strong that they were able to
obtain state support and establish
themselves as official national
doctrines but far beyond the boundaries
in which race thinking and class
thinking have developed into obligatory
patterns of thought free public opinion
has adopted them to such an extent that
not only intellectuals but great masses
of people will no longer accept any
presentation of past or present facts
that is not in agreement with those with
these views that's Henner rent her
analysis during the war became part of
her later work called the origins of
totalitarianism those views dominated
20th century thought and they continued
to the present day it is not surprising
that Capra's films came to be understood
in terms of those economic or social
theories by american critics as well he
was often thought to be a populist but
Capra did not assume that a virtuous
public opinion existed in the people and
a reform required nothing more than
mobilizing the people Capra was well
aware that the moderate that mott the
modern public is created by modern mass
media and it was the techniques used by
mass media that small and mass society
which posed a great danger to individual
freedom Capra insisted that his film
and I'm quoting him embodied the
rebellious cry of the individual against
being trampled into an orc by massive
mass production mass thought mass
education mass politics mass wealth mask
and format end of his quote he did not
assume that mass power could be used the
mass power could be used on behalf of
fundamental transformation of society
and economy he did not think such change
would bring about a future good or could
in any way write a historic wrong the
problems that American America face
could not be understood with reference
to progressive theories of history nor
could they be solved by economic or
social revolution political corruption
or factionalism is James Madison called
it is sewn into human nature Capra did
not advocate social or economic reform
as ends in themselves any reform must be
done on behalf of a moral education for
the purpose of moral regeneration I know
that many of you will see mr. Smith goes
to Washington Capra had his doubts about
making mr. Smith after he was present in
the news conference held by FDR 1939
outlaw outlining some of the great
problems that faced the United States he
wondered whether it was a good time to
make a comedy-drama about political
corruption he decided to visit the
lincoln memorial where he saw a boy
reading Lincoln's work to an elderly man
he said and I quote from him we must
make the film if only to hear a boy read
Lincoln to his grandpa Capra and a left
the Lincoln Memorial and these are his
words with his grote with this growing
conviction about our film the more
uncertain are the people of the world
the more they need a ringing statement
of America's democratic ideals the soul
of our film would be anchored in Lincoln
our Jefferson Smith would be a young a
blink
tailored to the rail splitter simplicity
compassion ideals human the panic was
over it is never untimely to yank the
Rope of freedoms Bell that's the end of
his quote when you see mr. Smith what is
surprising about it is where Capra
locates corruption was not uncommon for
FDR to attack the economic royalists or
the private corruption of corporations
and monopolies it was the government and
the unions that would establish the
political and social institutions to
combat the reactionary forces of the
private realm but Capra showed the
corruption to be in the political realm
was the politicians who had become
corrupt and they usurp the institutions
of government on behalf of its own
purposes Jefferson Jefferson Smith knows
nothing about the actual government in
Washington his father who he Revere's
was killed not defending a union but an
individual prospector against the mining
syndicate that was likely in cahoots
with the Union Capra sets his movie in a
deliberately timeless place there is no
mention of depression or impending war
there is no indication of partisanship
what is meant to live in the movie are
the speeches and writings of those
founders that have been carved in stone
but are now forgotten by those who hold
the offices Jefferson Smith's purpose is
to bring them back to the Senate if not
for those in Washington then for all
those who believe in the principles of
freedom in the movie Smith all often
points to the lighted Capitol dome where
the people are represented and tells his
tell Saunders that's what's got to be in
it and I'm quoting from the movie I want
to make that come to life for every boy
in this land yes and all light it up
like that too you see boys forget what
their country means by just reading the
land of the free and history books and
they get to be men they forget even more
or Liberty is too precious a thing to be
buried in books miss Saunders he's
talking to miss Saddler men should hold
it up in front of them every single day
of their lives and say I'm free to think
and to speak my ancestors couldn't I can
and my children will boys will want to
grow up remembering that that's from the
speak from the movie the only program
that Smith advocated was one that was an
investment in the future a boy's camp
which would educate them concerning the
principles of their country moreover it
was not to be paid for by govern but
only alone from government to be paid
for by the boys themselves later he says
in the same movie mr. Smith bring the
Capitol dome back to the ethical Center
where she belongs just get up off the
ground that's all I asked get up there
with that lady that's up on top of this
Capitol dome that lady that stands for
liberty take a look at this country
through through her eyes if you really
want to see something and you won't just
see scenery you'll see the whole parade
of what man's carved out for himself
after centuries of fighting and fighting
for something better than just jungle
law fighting so that he can stand on his
own two feet free and decent like it was
created no matter what his race color or
creed that's what you'd see there's no
place out there for graft or greed or
lies or compromise with human liberties
and if that's what the grown-ups have
done with this world that was given to
them then we'd better get these boys
can't start it fast and see what the
kids can do and it's not too late
because this country is bigger than the
Taylors are you or me or anything else
great principals don't get lost once
they come to light they're right here
you just have to see them again for
capra like Lincoln the principles are
there the problem is how to make the
people see them again
the politicians in Washington when this
movie came out did not like their
portrayal in the movie many tried to
keep the movie from being shown kapor
himself however thought it was a ringing
defense of democracy and he refused he
along with Harry Cohn who headed
Columbia studios refused the request not
to release and the people agreed with
cap it was a tremendous success not only
in America but throughout the world in
1942 just a month before the Nazi
occupation of France was to begin the
Vichy government asked the French people
what films they wanted to see before
American and British films would be
banned by the Germans the great majority
wanted to see mr. Smith one theater in
Paris played the movie every night for
30 straight nights before the Germans
occupation by the time America ended
entered World War two Capra had become
the most popular and honored Hollywood
director of the previous decade yet four
days after Pearl Harbor capper who was
president of the Screen directors guild
in Hollywood left his lucrative career
to join the armed force he was sent to
Washington and was given an office right
next to the army chief of staff general
george c marshall marshall was very much
worried that millions of men would be
constricted conscripted many right off
the farm most of whom would have little
idea of why we were fighting and what we
were fighting for Marshall made clear to
Capra what he wanted and I'm quoting
Marshalls comments to Capra I want to
nail down with you a plan to make a
series of documented factual information
films the first in our history that will
explain to our boys in the army why we
are fighting and the principles for
which we are fighting you have an
opportunity to contribute enormously to
your country
and the cause of freedom are you aware
of that third and capra of course was
and he was nearly cowed by the
assignment he he got he had never made a
documentary before he had no idea of
what to do later he explained what he
thought needed to be done he would
dramatize the difference between the
countries at war by using their own
films and documentaries he said he
merely wanted to reveal the difference
between freedom and slavery or tyranny
he never thought of his documentaries as
propaganda but of course after the war
this series was referred to as merely a
propaganda film Capra didn't think they
were propaganda because he thought they
simply recognized the permanent human
dilemma the problems of war and peace
reveal the distinction between right and
wrong or good and evil or justice and
injustice the fundamental alternative
and politics is between freedom and
slavery or democracy and tyranny I think
Winston Churchill or George Marsh would
have agreed with cap they were not would
have agreed with capper on why we fight
series was not pop again Winston
Churchill said and I'm quoting him I
have never seen or read any more
powerful statement of our cause or of
our rightful case against the Nazi
tyranny end quote they were not
propaganda Capra thought because they
made the rightful case against dear
against tyranny Churchill insisted that
those films be shown to every British
soldier soldier and that they be shown
in every theater in England so the
British could see them the end of the
war Marshall awarded Capra the
Distinguished Service Medal 1945 on the
recommendation of Winston Churchill a
few years late
kapor was given the order of the british
empire medal in 1962 after the war with
the danger gone it was clear that the
intellectuals of the West had not
understood the phenomenon of tyranny
because they had rejected the print the
principles of freedom as understood by
nature or natural right the lib the
Liberals had fought the Nazis are
fascists after the war they could only
see conservatives as enemies because
they understood politics in terms of
social and economic social or economic
theories derived from history Capra had
remained within the horizon of the
American founders in link he had
understood in the words of political
philosopher Leo Strauss and I quote the
experience of history unless in the less
ambiguous experience of the complexity
of human affairs may blur but they
cannot extinguish the evidence of those
simple experiences regarding right and
wrong which are at the bottom of the
philosophic contention that there is a
natural right historicism either ignores
or else distorts those these experiences
Strauss had noted why it was so
important for historians and artists to
recognize those simple experiences of
right and wrong and he gave you the
reason why he thought so he said and I
quote again natural right must be
mutable in order to be able to cope with
the inventiveness of wickedness what
cannot be decided in advance by
universal rules what can be decided in
the critical moment by the most
competent most conscientious statesman
on the spot can be made visible as just
in retrospect to all the object the
objective discrimination between extreme
actions which were just an extreme
actions which were unjust is one of the
noblest duties of the hiss
Dorian and I think capper understood his
his his art in that way as well but the
historians and the intellectuals
themselves the artists under the spell
of history animated by social science
methodology could not understand the
phenomenon of Tiran after the war they
found it difficult to praise the virtues
of democracy because those virtues were
dependent upon eternal principle derived
from an understanding of natural right
Capra's last great movie was It's a
Wonderful Life just before making it he
said to the LA Times and I'm quoting
there are just two things that are
important one is to strengthen the
individuals belief in himself and the
other even more important right now is
to is to combat a modern trend toward
atheism he said that movie mr. wonderful
life sums up my philosophy filmmaking
and I quote again from here first to
exalt the worth of the individual to
champion man plead his causes protest
any degradation of his dignity spirit or
divinity Capra knew that the Hollywood
class the Hollywood class would not
remain the same in terms of movie make
those personal historical categories of
class and race have become political and
self-indulgence self expression had
replaced those simple virtues that
required self restraint in his 1971
autobiography he wrote and I'm quoting
again the winds of change blew through
the dream factories of make believe tour
it's a tour at its criminal and tattered
the hedonist the homosexuals the home
team Ophelia act bleeding hearts the God
haters the quick buck artists who
substituted shock for talent all cried
shake him rattling god is dead long live
pleasure nudity yeah wife swapping yeah
liberate the world from prudery
emancipating our films from morality
kill for thrill shock shock to hell with
the good in man dredge up his evil shock
that's capless quote in his own
autobiography he had come to believe and
I quote this sentence last one
practically all the Hollywood film
making of today is stooping to cheap
salacious pornography in a crazy bastard
ization of a great art to compete for
the patronage of deviance harsh words
for an industry that had been
fundamentally transformed and this is
only 1971 the movies have gotten a lot
worse than he thought 1982 when Capra
was in his 85th year he was awarded the
American Film Institute's lifetime
achievement award in his acceptance
speech he touched on the things most
personal and professional that had been
most important in his life the first was
the memory of his voyage to America he
celebrated his sixth birthday in
steerage on a 13-day voyage across the
Atlantic he recalled the lack of privacy
ventilation and the terrible smell he
said the most degrading place you could
ever be but he also remembered the
ship's arrival in New York Harbor when
his father brought him on death and
showed him the statue of the great lady
holding a torch above the land they were
about to enter he recalls his illiterate
peasant father's excitement at the state
of the Statue of Liberty and hisses the
quote from his father Chico look look at
that that's the greatest light since the
Star of Bethlehem that's the light of
freedom remember that freedom Capra
remembered in his speech to the
Hollywood elite that night so many years
later he revealed the formula for his
whole art of movie
he said and he's I'm quoting from your
speech the art of Frank Capra is very
very simple it's the love of people had
two simple things to this love of people
the freedom of each individual and the
equal importance of each individual and
you have the principle of which upon
which I based all of my films in
conclusion it's hard to think of a
better way to describe Frank Capra's
view of the world in America's place in
fulfilling its purpose than to turn to
another great American who also made his
living in the world of motion pictures
that was before he became president of
the United States Ronald Reagan was a
friend and admirer a Frank Capra they
were very much alike the inscription
that Reagan wanted on his tombstone that
till his library there in Simi
California could have been written by
Frank Capra Reagan's tombstone reads I
know in my heart that man is good that
what is right will always eventually
triumph and there's purpose and worth to
each and every life end quote that's
that's that's on Reagan's tombstone both
Capra and Reagan look to a benevolent
and enduring Providence and the best in
man's nature is the ultimate ground of
political right for both of them like
Lincoln America was more than a
geographical location where citizens
shared only a common blood religion or
were merely a part of a common culture
or tradition rather it was a place where
a new and enlightened understanding of
the laws of nature and reason or
nature's God had made it possible to
establish those principles of equality
and liberty that gave purpose and worth
to each and every life but those lives
can only be purposeful and worthwhile in
the service of humph something higher
than mere life or in the adult mere
indulgence of the self kapor was aware
that the moral foundation established by
those principles as well as belief in
God had become endangered by the
transformations that occurred in
American life in the aftermath of World
War two it was for that reason that the
great problems of political life as he
understood them could not be an could
not be understood in terms of those
economic and social reforms that
required big government Capra's films
were about moral regeneration he saw the
necessity of moral education to preserve
and revive that kind of education that
would ensure the preservation are in a
statin and maintain the conditions of
freedom he knew it was impossible to be
indifferent to the moral conditions of
freedom for in a democracy the people
must not only participate in the rule of
others they must learn how to govern
themselves in his last and perhaps most
personal tribute to his adopted country
capper was reminded of the time when his
parents got off the train at union
station in Los Angeles after that long
journey across the country way back in
1903 you said that when he they got off
the train his mother and father got on
their knees and kissed the ground Capra
told his assembled audience one that had
just honored him some 80 years after
that event of his own feelings
concerning America his last words to his
audience was for America just for living
here I kissed the ground Capra did not
believe that he had a right to be a
citizen of the United of America not
even birth in America can confer such a
moral right rather he was grateful for
the privilege of living in America
because he knew that the preservation of
freedom offers not only economic
opportunity but also establishes a duty
for all of its citizens to preserve the
conditions of freedom not only for
themselves but for their posterity only
those willing to bear the burdens of
freedom have a right to its rewards
for capra the real America was to be
understood in terms of its virtues which
are derived from its principles in his
view his art was dedicated to keeping
those virtues alive by making those
principles live again in the speeches
and deeds of that most uncommon
phenomenon of American history the
American common man it was the deeds the
smiths and the doe's the simple
unsophisticated small town common
America American that cappers celebrated
in his movies but for Capra like his
friend John Ford no one epitomized
epitomized this phenomenon better than
Abraham Lincoln when American
intellectuals and artists rejected the
virtues and principles of the founders
the good of the past could no longer be
meet made meaningful to the present good
of the past could no longer be made
meaningful to the present on the other
hand Capra thought the real America was
embodied in its principles he knew it's
past was a treasure to be cherished but
for the new intellectual Lili the past
was understood as a misfortune as
something to be overcome perhaps that
was the view of your speaker last night
when that occurred celebration of the
heroes of the past like Lincoln came to
be seen as naive as something akin to a
feel-good fairytale Capra's fate as an
artist was tied up in that
transformation of the meaning of America
I'm afraid its moral regeneration which
Capra had hoped to bring about will
require more than a cap it will require
a link thank
thank you very much dr. barrini we have
some time for questions so please raise
your hand and the microphone will be
brought to you student questions are
encouraged as well thank you thank you
very very much I particularly
appreciated your conclusion you came to
such a different pass about cop Capra
from what we heard last night I'd like
to hear you account for that difference
because I prefer yours well I think that
it's it's it's not hard to account for
that difference because that generation
that was that was that came of age in
the 1960s came to understand the new
America merica that that was
contemptuous of contemptuous of its past
its past had to be overcome and so they
came to understand the goodness of
American terms of these historical
categories that I've talked about so the
bigger the big profit they look through
the lens of race or class or gender or
any of these these these personal
categories to begin to try to understand
somebody like Capra or Ford or Lincoln
or any of those people that's it's not
possible to understand that earlier
generation they did not think in these
kinds of categories and of course there
are differences in human beings they all
understood that there were problems in
in in politics that Lincoln had to face
that were that were such things as
slavery but all those things were
understood in terms of principles and so
if you begin your study of the past by
establishing the present as the standard
by which to judge the path a past that
couldn't possibly have seen itself in
the way we now understand our
and why do we think that our present is
so superior to theirs and yet that's the
Assumption right now we're right oh they
were racist they were sexist they were
homophobic or whatever you want to say
all of that of course presuppose that
the moral superiority is in is in the
hands of the contemporary generation
that is all completely manufactured and
it's wholly problematic and with the
transformation of the regime that too
will be changed so yeah I think the
problem with historians is of course
they understand history and anything in
the past has to be overcome by the
present so we're living with the modern
prejudice which Capra didn't live by or
understand and I'm sure any of that
generation of the 30 it wasn't only
Capra that made good movies and decent
movies in the 30s now view the 40s was
important the war was important they all
had they all saw if you look at the
great directors of that period that went
to war Capra was one John Ford was one
William Wyler John Huston all of those
directors that went to war when they
came back after the war had a very
different understanding of what what the
problem was going to be George Stevens
that was another great director every
one of them understood and as which was
really sobered by what they were up
against and they learned the lessons of
the of the struggle between those
principles democracy and freedom as
opposed to those principles of despotism
and slavery George Stevens who was one
of the great comedy directors before the
war never made a comedy after the John
Ford who made many great films the turn
to Westers to try to revive and
understand
inning of the virtues because you
couldn't talk about them in the present
the Hollywood was being changed the
whole culture was being changed in that
period after the war it took a period of
time of course Capra wrote his
autobiography that quote i made i was
already just he probably wrote that in
nineteen seventy but the it was clear
where the where the elite taste was
going where the intellectuals were doing
and this is only the cultural aspect
we're seeing the political aspects of
this transformation as well when i read
to you from hannah read her book came to
become the origins of totalitarianism
it's very difficult to prevent these
categories from requiring totalitarian
government in order to impose these
categories on a whole population when
you have all of these necessities that
to equalize these various kinds of
categories that arise from these from
the class or race or any of these things
it's very difficult to do it within the
framework of a limited government you
need unlimited power of government to
impose these because these things are
these things human beings by nature
don't understand themselves or don't
these natural tendencies that human
beings have they can be moderated they
can be ameliorated they can through
education be made better but the
essential character of human beings
selfishness goodness evil unselfishness
these are categories of human behavior
they're very unpredictable in human
beings and but you can't get rid of and
I think these great directors understood
that and made different kinds of movies
after the war because they understood
that America was changed and by the end
of the 60s of course they began to
reinterpret the past
do you think Frank Capra might have
envisioned himself as a sort of
Jefferson Smith after the war to try to
uphold the founders virtues for America
in his movies uh I think I think when he
did jefferson when he did mr. Smith he
had still some hope that that the war
would teach us something would teach the
democracy something but I think by that
the at the end of the war when he made
it's a wonderful life I don't think he I
think he had a very much darker vision
of America and I think if you watch that
film which people think it's a feel good
film but that movie is a dark mood and
that movie I think Capra portrays what
he sees as the future for America uce
portrays Bedford Falls that small city
that still retained the kinds of
institutions such as the family that
made it possible to have friendship and
all of the things that are necessary for
the virtues of self-government he saw
that as the possibility of he showed
that as a picture and he showed Potter's
pottersville as the more likely future
and the pottersville is is is is the
town that that is a kind of Dante's
Inferno morally it and the problem with
it as he saw it in the it's a wonderful
life I think is that George Bailey
carrot that James Stewart character
himself did not appreciate the small
town he wanted to get out of the town
too and and so the the problem there is
as Capra saw it how to how to reach how
to recreate maintain
the kind of community that's conducive
to human happiness that requires family
friendship and civic virtues and that's
one of his films where the woman the
Donna Reed character is not the
sophisticate world the smart woman of
the of the big city has say Jean Arthur
was in Washington or or in mr. deeds
goes to town she was the simple
housewife and cappers way of saying of
looking at this really I think it
clearly very dark because the only thing
that's going to save them is divine
intervention Clarence the angel has to
show them what life would be like
without George Bailey both for his wife
and for the town and of course so it's
hard to say that that's a very
optimistic move and it's also the movie
that probably was the end of Capra's
attempt to try moral a moral education
for America in terms of its in terms of
its principles I think he was he was not
very optimistic about America in in that
period he made a few more movies but I
think he saw what was coming with the
intellectual transformation with the
transformation in the in the culture and
politics of America in those years but
his star faded in the 50s but by the 80s
and perhaps Reagan had something to do
with the fact that there was a kind of
attempt to re-establish some of the
conditions of limited government again
that that Capra's Capra's films became
popular again in that period so when you
do something like that or you write a
book they don't simply die
but it's hard to make certain things
resonate in times that are not conducive
to those kinds of arguments the real the
real are the the great opinion about
Capra that would exist among in the film
schools are among the intellectuals is
McBride's it surely isn't mine that it
that's the opinion that Dominic
McBride's opinion you have to recreate
the arguments that I've made you have to
recreate them by reestablishing the
ground that made those ideas meaningful
when they're not in so for a person like
McBride he just wouldn't he couldn't
understand the meaning of say those
simple experiences that established the
ground of a natural right he's too
sophisticated remember one of the lines
in the mr. Smith when Jean Arthur says
it's a crime to be as wised up as we are
she's talking to the other reporter she
recognizes we're so smart we've
outsmarted ourselves and she recognized
because Jefferson Smith recreated in her
the experience of that kind of simple
integrity that made all of that
sophistication fall away now that's hard
too that's hard to do real life
thank you
thank you so much uh it's it's almost
it's a relief to hear you talk about our
country the morality of Frank Capra the
meaning of his life his early life as
well as his life that we all shared in
film and I frankly was saddened by
McBride and his interpretation and
revelations of the sins of Frank Capra
and I kept saying no no that can't be
and he says he said also that well uh
Frank Capra's films after he had been
the war we're different well of course
they were different anybody here who
experienced war ah did come back
different there was a change it was like
Jimmy Stewart when Jimmy Stewart came
back after 25 missions flying over
Germany he came back a different human
being he lost that wonderful innocence
that mr. Smith had and I just wanted to
thank you so much well for your
interpretation and love of this
no I'm afraid when you are a biographer
that one of the quotes that I gave you
from from Professor Leo Strauss about
the necessity of revealing those
important simple things that hath did
that has to be done by the artist and
the historian to show that these events
teach us something that they teach us
something and the capper I think
understood that these these are simple
moral lessons moral truth a problem with
with the scholars after the war and
these the university trained historian
is that they came to understand the past
as they understood the past as something
that had to be overcome they hated the
past so in a certain way they hated the
old America they hated that that that
that understanding of America that
animated America all the way up through
the 60 what they like about America is
after six that's what they like and when
you look at when you when you distort
the past by establishing the moral
superiority of the present without
reference to what is right or wrong or
the more the possibility of seeing right
or wrong what you end up doing is you
can make the facts conform to your
preconceptions and and so you know the
Capra was interested in in the public
things that he did every human being has
flaws there's no question about that and
Capra may have had some maybe he was
after 50 years after he lived his life
maybe he was wrong in a few of the
details of his life or may but I read
the reviewers of McBride because many of
the ordinary reviewers of McBride's book
said every time there was even a
judgment call about whether tapri or
or or McBride's position was right and
it was not possible to have a factual
McBride always was against cap
everything he did was to under undermine
cap in his book become but I what I
tried to show today is that the reason
he wanted to do that is not just care
the reason is he did not like the old
America he did not like how Americans
were because he thinks that capper
actually did think in racial categories
or but Capra lived in a world where
those differences exist they weren't
paramount in the way they thought about
human beings that's just the way things
were conventionally in those times and
and so to to to to establish those moral
categories to make judgments about
character is impossible what you do when
you make those judgments as you deny
character it's not possible to establish
character without reference to something
outside the virtues themselves have to
establish that character even as late as
Martin Luther King's 1964 speech when he
said I have a dream that one day my
children will be judged not by the color
of their skin but the content of their
character what is it what is
unintelligible about that statement
right now it's impossible to make
judgments about human character we only
make judgments about the color of skin
the race the gender that orientate all
personal things that have become
political and dominate how we think
about these questions for Capra for Ford
character was the thing character was
the thing and character if you have
character you try to hide your flaws for
one thing you're not proud of them and
there's a great philosopher French
philosopher once said that hypocrisy is
the tribute that Vice paste
Virg but that's impossible now to think
in that way for for the the intellection
somebody way in the back I think we have
time for one more question
everyone's thank you very much me that
okay they get some water
you